these Mercedes employees at the Hamburg
plant have it made a well-paid secure
job and the Mercedes star on their
jackets these workers only get to wear
reflective vests dryness is an external
company that pays less money and the
contract company employees aren't doing
just anything they are responsible for
the entire logistics system nothing at
the Mercedes plant functions without
them semi was Lottie and his colleagues
are fed up working longer hours for 800
euros less is not fair and if I provided
us using to demonstrate that means we're
second class people here we do the same
work but don't get the same money you
always hear the slogan equal pay for
equal work but we certainly don't have
it here that's a much to the dislike of
their company they founded a works
council and are holding a meeting in a
new office they want to fight for more
pay and a collective wage agreement
Gladys is outsourcing this outsourcing
to contract companies the cleaning lady
gets more than you do because she has a
collective wage agreement to throw it
also some of the men get more than
others and no one seems to know why
axial-flow x all that is it one is my
problem of my snow chief my problem is
that as a shift Foreman I get a fixed
salary of fifteen hundred and ten euros
and another 500 a month as a bonus but
I'm married and have a child I'm always
biting my nails because they can take
this bonus away at any time we merely
come on me didn't I hug you Bundy motion
me respect name
semi was lottie a father himself was
willing to take a risk and become head
of the works council toy toy toy yeah
like that's new yahoo wish me luck
you've had a works council since last
december we're writing history as they
say we are history at our company isn't
uh yeah i think we're the only works
council that's properly organized with
the union to give their self union
backing is crucial seminars Lottie has
visited the metalworking union
headquarters often in recent weeks he
needs support and gets it from Emmanuel
glass glass says no wage increase has
ever come without a union back struggle
in the fight to have their demands met
workers may have to risk losing their
jobs the sefira and deems in the it's
disastrous to say we want work at any
price we want good jobs with a living
wage we can't have people working for so
little that they need assistance from
the taxpayers and all the other workers
via social welfare contributions while
the company rakes in its profits
dartford sperm on downton amazon
convince eat horse meo Slainte and the
other members of the works council today
is an important day behind the backs of
raynaud's and mercedes they organized
their first meeting they are ready for
anything even a strike if need be mesaaz
machine when viet something has to
happen if we don't get things rolling
nothing else will be not Mar the muck
the herbs without a senate side it all
takes time patience and strong nerves
but I'm certain we'll manage it even the
shuttle we know I just know well yeah
the berks council has to convince the
workers that the struggle is worthwhile
they want 500 euros more pay and a fair
collective wage agreement just like
their Mercedes colleagues even if they
are hired by a contract company but
there's still a long way to go